hello hello my name is Miguel no rule
welcome to sintra a World Heritage Site
not a city where there's lots to see and
do and i'm going to show you around
that's a given yet cynthia center is an
exciting place why me I love walking
through the streets and people want the
bench there brick mojo beside me hello
the shower sumir we all greet one
another didn't ya everyone here enjoys
the colors the shadows it's so full of
life sintra is this vibrant deep diphu
supra Ines de sintra is the town of the
oldest palace here is the National
Palace for 800 years it was a royal
summer residence unique insight often
that Yara all the next is our next stop
is the Castello does more of shasta
lodos Morrow's besides the moors castle
yes teach us la i'm a descendant of the
castles conquerors he's a bog the castle
was built to protect this beautiful
region bus ought fatigue and sake hailey
from here you can see Lisbon and the
ocean Oh Tiana breakin so here couldn t
on this is another jet before done the
palacio de pena palacio de pinna I'd
[ __ ] me action it's like a fairy tale
fallen that's what colors the atmosphere
the mix of architectural styles from the
Arab influence to german romanticism
thought it reflects everything you can
find in the region to fit in these
yes in thia and then meet the here we
are under franciscan monastery beautiful
in its simplicity Oh Jane I man and
nature are in harmony here in a way
that's unique and so I not it's
wonderful I not only the man 11 was
dusky Phil is gunstar the sister gang so
then thesis the way to the monks ruined
City franciscana CZ in here the entrance
is only one metre twenty hi so when you
go in you expressed your humility
because you had to bow your head boy
give dahi night this is where the monks
would have spent their lives you met you
that's geared up to tinker this is also
part of what makes sintra special the
coast Sheldon it's beautiful with its
white and blue waves yeah I'm in the
middle here at the edge of the world
combo that all car near sintra I'll say
goodbye hey calm I hope you've enjoyed
the tour and come and see it for
yourself
you